hi I'm Nicole Clark and my project is
working on developing the iOS version of
App Inventor is democratized
cross-platform mobile development now a
big thing about App Inventor is that
it's block based visual programming and
so it means that when you're developing
an arien application you don't actually
need to know Java or anything up the
like now when it comes to iOS
development there are still very large
barriers to entry one you need to know
swift 2 you need to have an iOS or Apple
device it has a Mac laptop and three the
cost of owning that device is pretty
high so what we wanted to do was develop
and democratize not only Android
development but also iOS development and
that's my project is working on I'm
working on developing the components for
the iOS version and the native language
of Swift Valley what you're able to do
is take your existing App Inventor
project and then compile it into either
an iOS or Android device now that I
worked on was developing components and
inherently there are a couple challenges
because the Android version already
existed for one we wanted to really keep
Android version as a standard so it
meant that we were doing things like the
map view we had translated that each
tile overlay match which already existed
on Android and for iOS that meant adding
in a custom tile overlay
additionally we wanted things like the
accelerometer sensor to use the same
coordinates because it'd be odd if you
ran the same app on I wasn't Android but
one had up going this way and the other
one had positive going this way so you
really needed to map that to be the same
we also wanted to keep the same human
interfaces that Apple had laid out
already and really not how that feel as
though you're using so that's something
that wasn't actually an iOS application
and lastly we had to deal with
permission handling which was dealing
with permissions at runtime and
accepting and rejecting them to follow
Apple did ultimately you've had some
pretty good results though by randomly
selecting 1.8 million applications we're
currently able to build 65.4 or 4% of
the applications and we put this in
perspective the Android version of App
Inventor has been around for eight years
and we just began to work on the iOS
version in this past year so I'd say
we're doing pretty well